drop the guns out  drop the gun  i need you to come out here  drop the gun now  you're getting shot  i don't want to shoot you  it doesn't have to be this way just tell  us what you have what we have to do to  make you comply  [Applause]  you understand  i need you to step away from the gun so  we can approach you and give you first  aid  you're going to be bit by a police dog  we fear that you're lying in weight and  waiting for us to approach you to harm  us  i see you moving  don't point the gun  slide the gun over and we can approach  you  can anybody get a fee  on that side to the right or no  hold on we can move up a little bit okay  i got a good spot right here  all right  just hang on a second  hey  you gotta slide that gun away  so we can approach you  still in his right arm the gun is still  on his right arm i believe it's in his  right hand right now  you